[موسيقى]
كثيره هي السيناريوهات التي نسجت حول
مستقبل مجموعه فاجنر ومصير رئيسها حتى قبل
الاعلان رسميا عن مصرعه في حادث تحطم
طائرته شمال موسكو واليوم وفي ظل الغموض
الذي يحيط بمصير المجموعه باتت الاسئله
اكثر الحاحا ففي رحله صعوده وعفوله ظلت
الكثير من المحطات غامضه في سيره هذا
الرجل الذي طالما تباهه بقوه مجموعته
ودورها الطلائعي في معركه بخموت باوكرانيا
او في بلدان عربيه وافريقيه وظل وفيا
لخطابه المتسم بنبره التهديد والوعيد حتى
اخر ظهور مصور له حيث بدا منتشقا رشاشه
واعدا بانه سيجعل روسيا اعظم وافريقيا
اكثر حريه فما الدوله الذي ينتظر فاجنر
بعد مصرع زعيمها رفقه كبار معاونيه وهل
طويت صفحتها كذراع عسكريه واقتصاديه
لموسكو وما مصير نفوذها في البلدان التي
كانت تنشط فيها خصوصا الافريقيه منها اهلا
بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم على مدى سنوات الماضيه ظلت
فاجنر واحده من اكثر ادوات النفوذ
الخارجيه لروسيا فقد لعبت دورا هاما في
ساحه القتال في سوريا واوكرانيا وعملت على
توسيع نطاق وجودها في افريقيا حيث تنشط
بشكل اكبر في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
وليبيا والسودان ومؤخرا في دول الساحل
الافريقيه عن مصير هذه المجموعه العسكريه
التي حظيت باهتماما كبير منذ الاعلان عن
تاسيسها قبل نحو 10 سنوات واهتماما اكبر
بعد تحطم طائره رئيس
يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه من
موسكو المحلل السياسي
من باريس الدكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم
السياسيه بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس ومن
واشنطن شون
الضابط السابق في قوات النخبه الامريكيه
والاستاذ بكليه الدفاع الوطني ومؤلف كتاب
المرتزقه الجدد الجيوش الخاصه وما تعنيه
للنظام اهلا بهم جميعا
بعد 24 ساعه من الغموض حول مسيره
ظهر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في اول
تصريحا رسميا له ليضع حدا لكل التخمينات
والتكانات بوتين اثناء على اعتباره رجلا
موهوبا لكنه ارتكب اخطاء كثيره ويبدو ان
تلك الاخطاء واخرها تمرده المسلح الذي سبق
ان وصفه بوتين بالخيانه والطعن في الظهر
هي التي غيرت مساره وعجلت برحيله فماذا
بعد رحيل بريغوشن من سيخلفه وما مصير هذه
المجموعه كادير عن عسكريه ساهمت في بسط
نفوذ موسكو والدفاع عن مصالحها في العديد
من البلدان خاصه في افريقيا التي اكد
بوتين ان اخر ظهور مصور
كان فيها
هذه لحظه كانت تحسب لها الحسابات وتنسج
لها السيناريوهات لم يكن معلوما باي طريقه
لكن التمرد فاغنر شهر يونيو الماضي في راي
اكثر المراقبين كان ايذانا بالفصل الاخير
في مسيره هذا الرجل في واجهه الاحداث
رحل اف جيني تاركا ارثا مثيرا للجدل في
العلاقات الدوليه
فشركه فاجنر التي اسسها عام 2014 اصبحت
اكثر من مجرد مجموعه مسلحه غير نظاميه
تشكل اليوم اداه تنفيذيه لصيغه غير
تقليديه في علاقات الدول التي تنشط فيها
قوه عسكريه تعدادها نحو 25 الف مقاتل
وامبراطوريه اقتصاديه تبرم عقودا بملايين
الدولارات مع حكومات مقابل خدمات عسكريه
ينتقل الحديث بشانها الان الى مرحله ماذا
بعد بريكوجين عزز التمرد الذي قاده
المجموعه شهر يونيو الماضي رغبه الكريم في
وضع مقاتل فاجنر تحت سيطره مباشره اما
باخداعهم لوزاره الدفاع او بوضع قياده
جديده
وكانت اوساط روسيه قد تحدثت سابقا عن
ضروره قطع راس فاجنر من اجل تحديد الاليات
النهائيه للتعامل مع المجموعه
طرح في منتصف يوليو الماضي اسم قائد بديل
محتمل
عقيد روسي متقاعد وعضون مؤسس ومدير تنفيذي
في مجموعه فاغنر تفيد وثائق للاتحاد
الاوروبي انه كان متورطا في قمع المدنيين
في سوريا وساهم مساهمه حاسمه في ترجيح
الكفه لصالح النظام في دير الزور
لكن الحسابات بشان مستقبل فاجنر لا تتوقف
عند هويه من يقود ثمه جبهات ظلت المجموعه
فيها نشطه حتى مع تازم العلاقه بين
الكرملين
ففي القاره الافريقيه تحتفظ فاجنر بسيطره
كبيره على مناجم تعدين الذهب والماس في
افريقيا الوسطى وتقدم خدماتها للنظام الذي
يقوده العسكريون في كل من مالي وبوركينا
فاسو وذكرت صحيفه
قلقه بشكل خاص من محاولاتها الوصول الى
النفط الليبي من خلال نشاطها المستمر الى
جانب قوات حفتر وفق الصحيفه
اما في اوكرانيا فقد فتحت على حلفائها
الاوروبيين جبهه تهديد جديده بنقل قواته
الى بيلاروسيا وتلك خطوه دفعت دولا
كبولندا وليتوانيا الى حاله استنفار على
حدودهما الشرقيه الان وقد رحل لا يعرف
بالتحديد كيف ستتاثر جبهه الحدود هذه وكيف
ستكون ادوار فاجنر في جبهه الشرق
الاوكراني المستمره معاركها
نرحب بضيوفنا من جديد ونبدا من موسكو
السيد افقيني
ما مستقبل فاقنر بعد رحيله زعيمها
تحيه لك وللساده المشاهدين والضيفك
الكريمين واضح تماما ان مستقبل يعني لا
يزال غامضا وذلك بسبب ان لا يمكن ان يتصور
المرء براي انا الشخصي
وجود بديل يعني يستجيب لنفس المعايير
ويتخذ نفس اساليب والطرق في نشاطه
وممارساته سواء في المجال العسكري او في
مجال البزنس او المجال الاعمال مثل ما كان
ذلك في افريقيا ولكن بطبيعه الحال الاوضاع
التي سوف طبعا تصود روسيا مستقبلا وحتى من
الان تفرض على مثل هذه الشركات او بدائل
المحتمل لها ان تواصل
ما قام به ومجموعته
التي ساهمت يعني مساهمه كبيره جدا سواء في
داخل روسيا او في الجبهات جبهات القتال
الاوكرانيه يكفي ان نذكر هنا معركه ضخمه
حيث يعود الى مجموعه الفضل الكبير في
حسمها او خارج روسيا في افريقيا ولكن براي
انا تحطم طائراته ومقتله ربما يؤثر سلبا
على
الاختيارات التي قد يقدم عليها القاده
الافارقه الذين ربما سوف يقفون موقف الحذر
اذا يمكن ان ياتي محل
وهذا الامر لابد ان يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
عند اعداد مجموعات مماثله تستطيع ان تحل
محل شركه
سنعود اكثر بالتفصيل لموضوع العلاقه مع
افريقيا
وفاينر لكن سيدروف هل هل يمكن ان ننتظر
اعاده هيكله لفاجنر او حتى تغيير اسمها او
ربما ايجادها بصيغه مختلفه تماما الان
يعني مهما تغير اسمها او سيبقى نفس الاسم
لدى هذه المجموعه الا انها لن تكون مثل ما
كانت ايام بريجوشن او في عهد بريجوجن لان
واضح تماما ان يعني كل ما قام به قامت به
هذه المجموعه
ومكتسباته ونجاحاته وكانت مرتبطه باسم رجل
واحد وهو زعيم هذه المجموعه وبالتالي لابد
ان يكون هناك ربما في بديل جديده او بديل
اخر لهذه المجموعه شخص
له نفس الصفات وله نفس
الميزات التي كان قد تمتها ووضع تماما انه
انشاء او تكوين صوره طبقا
للاصل امر في غايه الصعوبه لاسيما اذا كان
الامر يتعلق بمثل هذه الشخصيه التي طبعا
كانت مليئه
بمختلف تناقضات سواء داخليه في علاقاته مع
القاده المسؤولين لا سيما في وزاره دفاع
الروسيه التنبؤ بالاوضاع بعد رحيل الزعيم
فاجنر انتشر في كثير من التصريحات نسال
ضيفنا من واشنطن سيد شون مكفيت مارك ميلي
رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه قال
بان غياب بريجوجن ستكون له تداعيات في
مناطق وجود فاجنر في العالم
هل فعلا تتحسب واشنطن لتغييرات من هذا
القبيل
انا لا اتفق مع ذلك لا اعتقد ان هنالك
تغييرا جذريا في اوكرانيا او في افريقيا
على الارض
فكروا في الامر كالتالي تمت شركه ولديها
ملاك جدد وهو بوتين وقد عوض
القاده من خلال تفجير طائره وسوف ربما يشد
على يد احدهم من القياده الوسطى يكون
مطواعا له وسيقوم بكل ما يامره به ليكون
وكيلا في افريقيا وايضا يستمر في اوكرانيا
بعيدا عن الاعلام لكي لا يكون جديد ولا
يكون سياسيا وما يجري الان هو ان بوتين
يريد
مجموعه لتعمل لحسابه لمد اذرعتي روسيا في
افريقيا لذلك لا اعتقد ان هنالك تغيير او
فرق في المستقبل يعني برايك استخلص بوتين
الدرس ولم يسمح اطلاقا بان تعاد التجربه
مره اخرى كهيكل نوعا ما له استقلاليه بين
قوسين
كلا اعتقد انه يقامر عندما
يستاجر احدهم مرتزقه هذه معامله انظروا في
الامر كالتالي نحن نفكر في الجنود كزوجات
والمرتزقه
كبائعات هواء وبالتالي فان هنالك خصومه
بين وزاره الدفاع وهذا معروف وعندما يتعلق
الامر بالمرتزقه فان ولائهم يمكن ان يشترى
ويمكن ان يتذبذبوا ويمكن ان يخونوا
وبالتالي فان الخيانه هي السمه الحرب التي
يقودها المرتزقه وبالتالي في حاله بوتين
بوتين يحاول ان يستخدم مرتزقته لكي يعزز
من سلطته عليهم ولكنه ما زال يقامر وهذا
سؤال وجيه سالتموه الدكتور زياد ماجد ربما
لديه بعض التحفظ على هذا التشبيه الذي
ذكرته
ما سبب هذا التحفظ كما رايت من من الملامح
لا يعني انا اتحفظ على كل تشبيهات تستخدم
المراه وتستخدم صفات خاصه بالنساء لاقامه
امثله سياسيه او غير سياسيه فقط من هذا
الباب تحفظت واذا سمحت لي فقط ربما اضيف
على الافكار التي طرحت ان ما كان يفيد
موسكو في حاله فاجنر بمعزل عن شخصها وطبعا
يمكن العوده الى ذلك هو ما يمكن تسميته
بالكلفه العسكريه المنخفضه لوكوست يعني
هناك مجموعه مرتزقه تعمل لدى شركه كانت
لديها العديد من الازرعه تستطيع تمويل
انشطتها بنفسها من خلال السطو على مناجم
او من خلال تقاضي اموال من رؤساء دول ومن
حكومات بحجه حمايه امنهم الشخصي لديها
ذراع اعلامي شاركت بمعارك في سوريا وفي
ليبيا كما اشار تقريرك وهي متهمه بارتكاب
الكثير من الجرائم في هذه الساحات قبل ان
تعرف جرائمها في اوكرانيا وفي افريقيا
الوسطى وفي امكنه اخرى يعني هناك كانت
كلفه منخفضه
تؤدي مهام قذره اذا صح التعبير يعني
الاستخدام هذا
وتستطيع موسكو التبرا بها منها عفوا من
جهه وتوظيفها لمفاوضات لاظهار ان لديها
اذرع وقدره على التاثير في اكثر من ساحه
بما يمكنها من التفاوض من تسويه هنا من
تصعيد هناك كانت تؤدي كل هذا الماء هذه
المهام وربما تضخمت الامور في راس
بريغوجين اذ ظن انه يستطيع ان يتخطى حدودا
معينه وتاريخه يظهر انه كان متقلبا واشار
الضيف من موسكو ان فيه الكثير من
التناقضات حكم بالسجن اكثر من مره في
الثمانينات بسبب جرائم وج كان طباخا
لبوتين ثم صار صاحب شركه مطاعم تعامل مع
الاعلام وكانت لديه اذرع اعلاميه دخل في
مجال الاعلام الاجتماعي والتواصل وكان له
ترولز او جيش الكتروني في نفس الوقت لديه
هذه الميليشيا يستخدم عبارات بذيئه في
خطابه وفي اظهار حصانته تجاه الطبقه
السياسيه واتجاه الجنرالات في روسيا لكنه
في نفس الوقت ادرك حدوده منذ فتره بعد
محاوله الانقلاب الفاشله
وجاء الرد عليه ببروده بعد انتظار بعد مده
من خلال تصفيته وبالتالي اصبح اي شخص
سيعرف ما تبقى من شركه فاجنر لان جزءا من
اذرعتها جرى يعني تشذيبه او جرى قطعه منذ
فتره اي شخص سيتولى مسؤوليته يدرك انه
بخطر وكل افراد فاجنر باتل لديهم سقف من
التوقعات فيما يخص
عليهم ان يمتثلوا
لحدود معينه لخطوط حمراء معينه وحتى او اي
شخص اخر يمكن ان ياتي مكانه سيكون ملزما
بقواعد جديده للعبه لا تتيح له تخطي او
اللعب خارج ما يمليه الكرملين وسيد
الكرملين او اجهزه مخابرات روسيه وهذا
سينعكس ايضا في علاقه فكنر مع الحكومات او
مع القوى في الدول حيث تنتشر لاسيما في
افريقيا التي اصبحت ملعبها الاقتصادي
والامني والسياسي الابرز اشرت مرتين
للاذرع العالميه هنا نسال سيدروف فعلا
ليست فقط جنود او معدات هي ايضا جيش
الكتروني محاوله للتاثير في الراي العام
وهناك حديث بعد مصر بريكويجن ان غرف
الدردشه في المواقع الاعلاميه القريبه من
من فاجنر بدات تتحدث عن ضروره الانتقام
لمصرعه هل هل تتوقع اي تطورات سلبيه في
هذا الاتجاه
انا شخصيا لا اتوقع ان هناك تطورات سوف
نراها على الارض مباشره وانما هذه الغرف
او غرف دردشه كما تفضلت ربما موجوده لكون
الكثيرين من عناصر فاجنر سواء اليك الذين
بقوا خارج اطار او وزاره الدفاع ولم يتم
دمجهم هناك او من بقي مع بريجوجل حتى ربما
اخر ايام حياته فانهم بطبيعه الحال ما
زالوا يتذكرون تلك الايام وتلك المحن
وتجارب والعمليات التي عاشوها معا بقياده
هذا الرجل الذي استطاع ربما ان يجمع حوله
اناسا في مختلف التخصصات والمجالات
وبواسطه ذلك كان قد تمكن كما اعتقد من
تحقيق نجاحات وكسب عواطف
الاوساط العريضه لاشيه على مستوى الشارع
الروسي
الكثير من الخطب والتصريحات والكلمات التي
قالها كانت لاول وهله تبدو انها تحمل ربما
صبغه شعبويه الا انه كان يريد ان يقول وهو
يتوجه الى الشعب كانه هو احد منهم وهو
معهم وهو ضد الفساد وضد القصور والتسيب في
صفوف القياده العسكريه وفي نفس الوقت انه
مخلص لوطنه ومخلص ووفي لرئيسه
ولتلك القضيه التي يخدم في سبيلها كل هذه
الصفات اعتقد كادت تحول شخصيه الى بطل
قومي على غرار تلك الابطال التي اشتهرت
بها روسيا في القرون الوسطى والذين كانوا
مثلا ضد القياصره ونظموا انتفاضات وتمردات
والى اخره ولكن اذا سلمنا بان المتوقع سيد
شونكفيت هو
نسخه جديده من من
هذه النسخه على الارجح كما تقول التقارير
لحد الان على الاقل لن يكون لها اي دور في
السياسه الداخليه الروسيه لن يكون لها اي
دور في حرب اوكرانيا ولكن ستركز عملها
بالاساس على الخارج وافريقيا بالدرجه
الاولى هل فعلا هذه هي سمات المرحله
المقبله
اعتقد انه يتعين علينا ان نفهم ان فانجر
ليست مجموعه واحده ولكنها مجموعتان هنالك
الحرس القديم في افريقيا والحرس الجديد
وهو في اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا
والحرس الجديد هي تالفوا من المجرمين
الذين اطلق صراحهم من السجون في سنه
الماضيه من قبل
وارسل الى جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا
ليقتلوا رايناهم في سوليدار وفي بخموت وهم
تم
ادماجهم في وزاره الدفاع الروسيه السؤال
الذي يثار هو من هم الحرس القديم وهم
مدربون على نحو الحسن
وهم بقوا خارج اوكرانيا في جل المعارك
بقوا في افريقيا وما فعله هو انه بنى
نموذج بزنس نموذج اعمال لا يحتاج الى
ادارته
يعرف ذلك ان هذا النموذج هو كالتالي يذهب
الى بلد فيها انقلاب كالنيجر او مالي او
ربما سيكون هنالك انقلاب تاج مولات
افريقيا الوسطى ويعقد الصفقه يقول انظروا
سوف استخدم مجموعه
وعضلاتها
لكي استحدث
ميليشيات تحاول ان تخدمكم انتم فقط وسوف
اقوم بحمل التي جيوشا الكترونيه وتشويه
سمعه والى ما هنالك لكي اجعلكم
مشهورين في بلادكم
الى ذلك اريد ان اصل الى الذهب او الغاز
الطبيعي
واريد منكم ان تولوا وجهكم شطر موسكو وليس
شطره الغرب وبالتالي تصبح دوله تنسجه على
روسيا وهو يرسل الذهب الى روسيا لكي
تستخدمه في حرب اوكرانيا هنالك مليار من
الدولارات من الذهب السوداني
اختفت وبالتالي هذا هو نموذج العمل الذي
يستخدمه جيوش الكترونيه موارد طبيعيه
ويعمل لكي يصل الى ارساء دعائم
اوتوقراطيات في افريقيا تولي وجهها وجه
موسكو وبوتين يريد ذلك
لن يوقف نموذج الاعمال هذا ولكن في
المرحله المقبله السيد زياد ماجد المرحله
المقبله لا يمكن
لبوتين وللكرملين ان ان يدعي ان هناك
مسافه ما بين موسكو وبين فاجنر يعني اذا
صح التعبير بموت بريغوجين اصبح هناك نوع
من التاميم الكامل
وبالتالي اي تحرك لها في المستقبل سيحسب
مباشره على الكريمليل هل هذا هو تحدي
الابرز ربما في المرحله المقبله
نعم بلا شك هذا سيكون تحديا كبيرا لان
المسافه التي كان يستطيع بوتين ان يدعيها
مع فاجنر كما حصل مره خلال المواجهه مع
الامريكيين في منطقه دير الزور في سوريا
او فيما يتعلق بالمشاركه في المعارك الى
جانب لواء حفتر في ليبيا او بعض الفظائع
التي ارتكبت في بوركينا فاسو وفي افريقيا
الوسطى كل هذه الامور الان في حال تعين
شخص جديد يعتبر مقربا من بوتين على راس
فاجنر تعني ان المسافه التي كانت قائمه
انتهت وان وزاره الدفاع او اجهزه
المخابرات او سطوه الكرمل المباشره موجوده
على هذه الشركه وعلى هذه الجماعه
وبالتالي يصبح موضوع الاستثمار فيها
مختلفا يرتبط بالسياسه الخارجيه المباشره
لروسيا وهذا سيكون مصدر قلق لبعض شركاء
فاجنور الذين كانوا بدوره ايضا بسبب
رغبتهم في الابقاء على بعض الجسور مع
الغرب يظهرون وكانهم يلجاون الى شركه خاصه
روسيه لحمايتهم ويقدمون لها في المقابل في
بعض الدول الافريقيه
عقود ترتبط بمناجم ذهب ترتبط بغاز ترتبط
بحمايه منشات اقتصاديه مقابل اموال طائله
وفي نفس الوقت يقولون للدول الغربيه ان
هذا امر مؤقت يرتبط بعقود مع شركه مع
مرتزقه وليس انحيازا واضحا لموسكو في اي
مواجهه او في اي ثنائيات مع دول غربيه هذا
ايضا سينتهي اذا باتت فاجنر ذراعا روسيا
رسميا مباشرا من دون تمويه او من دون اي
التباسات فبالتالي نحن بلا شك امام مرحله
جديده الشخص سيكون مرتبط بالكريم لان اكثر
من بريكوجين المسافه ستصبح شبه معدومه
وهذا س يفرض تحديات جديده على الشركه اذا
استمرت وعلى انشطتها وعلى علاقه بها من
قبل شركائها اليوم على كل من بين الاسماء
المطروحه الان حاليا كبديل لبروغين هناك
على راس المجموعه راس مجموعه
يبرز اسم اندريه تروشيف وهو عقيد سابق في
الجيش الروسي واحد ابرز مؤسسي فانا نتوقف
في هذه الورقه التعريفيه عند اهم المحطات
في مسيرتها
الخامس من ابريل عام
1962 في مدينه دينينغراب
شارك في الغزو السوفيتي لافغانستان خلال
الثمانينيات وحصل على وسام النجمه الحمراء
كما حصل مرتين على وسام الشجاعه ووسام
الاستحقاق لمشاركته في حرب الشيشان يعد
التروشيف من ابرز مؤسسي مجموعه فاجنر وقد
شارك في الهجوم الروسيه على تنظيم الدوله
للسيطره على مدينه تدمر السوريه وفي
ديسمبر كانون الاول من عام 2016 ونظير
قيادته لفاجنر في سوريا لقبه بوتين ببطل
روسيا وقلده وسام المجد وهو اعلى وسام في
روسيا وفي العام التالي نقلت روشيف الى
قسم الطوارئ في مستشفى سامبوتسبورغ وخضع
لتدخل طبي عاجل اثر اصابته خلال القتال في
سوريا كما يعتقد ان التروشيف شارك في هجوم
فاجرار على موقع امريكي في دير الزور عام
2018 في مايو ايار الماضي لعبت روشيف دورا
بارزا في معاركنر للاستيلاء على مدينه
بخموت شرقيه اوكرانيا
في مطلع شهر يوليو تموز اعلنت قناته
تيليجرام المملوكه لفاجنر ان المجموعه
طردت تروشيف كما عممت وثيقه تشير الى ان
هو من ابلغ عن تمرد المجموعه وانه امر
الوحدات العسكريه بالتنحي خلال هذا التمرد
ونقل عن الرئيس الروسي في اجتماع له معقده
فاجنر بعد محاوله التمرد انه اعلمهم بنيته
تعيين اندريتروشيف على راس المجموعه
اذا هذا هو صاحب الشعر الرمادي كما يوصف
سيدروف هل هو الاكثر حضو الان
زعامه باجنر
ابدا ان تمرده لم يكن موجها ضد الرئيس
الروسي وانما ضد اولئك الذين يقودون
المؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه وزاره الدفاع
وهيئه الاركان العامه وهو انتقدهم لبعض
القصور وتسيب في نشاطهم وبالنسبه للمرشحين
الاخرين يمكن القول بان هم ايضا ربما
اسمائهم وارده في تلك القائمه التي لا شك
ان الكريميوم قد بدا او سيبدا قريبا في
دراستها واختيارها ولكننا نعلم من جهه
اخرى
بان الرئيس بوتين معروف بطباعه المفاجئ او
بقراراته المفاجئه للجميع لانه مثلا قبل
تعيين سيد ميشوستين لمنصب رئيس الوزراء لم
يكن هذا الاخير لم يكن اسمه واردا في
قائمه المرشحين ولكن الرئيس الروسي قدم
بتعيينه مفاجاه كبيره هكذا نفس شيء يمكن
ان يحرص مع من ياتي محل
ولكن سيد سواء كان او غيره كيف سيجد
العلاقه مع الحكام الافارقه لانه
نسج علاقات خاصه وعلاقات مصلحيه من البزنس
ومن الامن كيف ستكون مهمه الخليفه
انا اعتقد بان الجواب عن هذا السؤال يمكن
ايجاده في قول ربما بناء ومن السخريه كما
بعض المعلومات تشير الى ان هذا القول او
هذه الجمله تعود الى احد كبار المسؤولين
الافارقه فقال اذا قرر
قررت روسيا او قرر الكريم سحب مجموعه
فاقدر او صاحب فاجنر منا فاننا سنجد او
سوف نستضيف او مسار يعني في تلميح الى
اسماء الموسيقريين الالمان والموسيقار
النمساوي الذين سمي باسمهم
شركه ماكدو وبالتالي هذا التصريح يمكن ان
نصل اليه على انه لا يوجد بالنسبه لبعض
القاده الافارقه مشكله في اختيار بديل
لشركه سواء داخل روسيا او ربما خارجها
وذلك في حاله سماء اصيبوا بخيبه الامل في
امكانيه الاتفاق مع شركه روسيه اخرى على
طرق التواصل والتفاعل في اثناء عمل هذه
المجموعه في افريقيا في انتظار بروز اسم
البديل سيد هل تعتقد بان هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه هذه المرحله الملتبسه بعد رحيل
بريغوجين ربما تربك العلاقات الروسيه مع
هذه الدول الافريقيه سواء في مالي او
افريقيا الوسطى او السودان او ليبيا او
غيرها
نعم اعتقد ان هنالك منطقه رماديه بين بين
تفضي الى التوتر لان العالم سيما
الطوما العسكريه في دول الساحل تنظر الى
موسكو والى فاجنر
وتتساءل ماذا يجري وسوف تقوم بحساباتها
ليصب ذلك في مصلحتها وايضا
كان رجلا استحدث
علاقه مع البشر
كانت هناك علاقات بين هو بين اشخاص وليس
مع مؤسسات لذلك لا يمكن ان ناتي بعقيد من
المؤسسه العسكريه
لننصبه كزعيم لفاجنر لكي يموت الجسوره مع
الاخرين انا اتفهموا لماذا يريد ذلك ليكون
مواليا له ولكن في النيجر الطعمه العسكريه
تشاهدوا ما يجري ولديهم خططهم واذا ما كان
الزعيم لا يروق لهم فانهم سوف يجدون ربما
بديلا كما قال الزميل واذا ما كانت
افراد فاجنر لا يحبذون الزعيم فانهم سوف
يبداوا بالاختفاء
وسيظهرون في
الديمقراطيه وسيعملون بعقود ربما حره
وبالتالي اعتقد انها تداعيات جيوسياسيه في
اوروبا وفي افريقيا ايضا هل معنى ذلك
دكتور زياد ماجد ان فاجنر بنسختها الجديده
ستجد صعوبه في مواصله نفس الوتيره في
العلاقه مع دول يعني مثلا على سبيل المثال
ليبيا او السودان او دورها في سوريا ان
كانت ما زالت هناك في هذه المواقع تحديدا
ربما
نعم اعتقد ستكون المرحله مختلفه ربما في
سوريا الحاجه اليها اقل بعد تغير الخريطه
السوريه وتحديدا في ظل وجود القوات
الايرانيه والمواليه لايران على الصعيد
العديد البشري على الارض لكن في ليبيا وفي
السودان وفي غيرهما ربما هناك ادوار
متغيره الحاجه لخبراتهم العسكريه الحاجه
لبعض العتاد الذي كان يمكن توفيره عبر
العلاقه بفاجنر والحاجه لغطاء او لربط ما
مع روسيا قائمه وضروريه لاطراف الصراع
لذلك قد نشهد تحولات وتغييرات والعلاقه
الشخصيه بلا شك في هكذا انواع من الصراعات
مهمه واي شخص سيخلف بريكوجين عليه ان يعيد
بناء علاقات ان يظهر حدود التبديل والتغير
ما هو المستمر وما هو الخاضع لحسابات
جديده وكل هذا طلب وقتا قد لا تكون دائما
اطراف الصراع قادره على احتمالي فنحن امام
مرحله جديده انما التشخيص لما هي
دور شركات مرتزقه من هذا النوع تدخل فيها
قضايا البزنس والاعمال والفساد والامن
والحمايه والمواجهات العسكريه والتوظيفات
في السياسه الخارجيه هذه ادوار جديده في
علاقات الدول اليوم ولا اعتقد انها ستنحسر
بل على العكس
خصخصت كل اشكال التعامل الامني والاقتصادي
والعسكري وادماجها ضمن بوطق سياسيه لا
سيما للدول غير الديمقراطيه هي مرحله
مقبله على المزيد من التطور
ويصعب التكهن بكل السيناريوهات حين يكون
النظام النظام مفاجات يعني كما هو الحال
في روسيا ونظام مبني على قرارات فرد ولو
ان تروشيف يبدو بسبب سجله
بسبب علاقاته وبسبب حرب الشيشان وليس فقط
افغانستان وكل ما شارك به في المرحله
الاخيره من صراعات ومن معارك ربما يكون
الاكثر قدره على الاستمرار في مهام فاغنر
انما في ساحات
ستتغير فيها بعض ديناميات العلاقه من بين
هذه التغيرات ربما سيد سيد روف وعلى ذكر
البزنس تحديدا هل المرحله المقبله ستكون
مرحله بوتين هو الزعيم الحقيقي بمعنى انه
لن يكون هناك اي شخص
بامكانه ان ان يؤسس امبراطوريه او شبكه
علاقات خارج
السياق الخاص بالكرملين هذه هي المرحله
المقبله مع افريقيا تحديدا
نعم هي احتمال ان تكون هذه المرحله مرحله
مقبله كما تفضلت ولكن انا لا اعتقد انه في
الماضي كان الامر يختلف اختلافا جذريا عما
يمكن ان يكون عليه الامر مستقبلا لانه
بالرغم من بعض الخلافات
والتناقضات القائمه بين
بعض القاده العسكريين الروسي
وبالرغم من بعض المشاكل التي احاطت
بالاعمال او البيزنس تابعه لبريجوجن الا
انه ظل دائما وفيا لراس النظام والرئيس
الروسي الشخصيا علما بان الرئيس الروسي
ولابد من لفت النظر الى ذلك اشار الى ان
علاقات قويه كانت تربطه
من القرن الماضي وهذا يعني ان كان دائما
ينظر اليه من قبل الكريم على انه رجل
موثوق والا ما كان من الممكن ان نتصور انه
يعني كان يمكن ان يصبح كما يسمى ويلقب
يلقب بطباخ بوتين الشخصي وبالتالي اعتقد
انه له فرق بينما كان عليه الامر وبينما
كان او يمكن ان يكون عليه مستقبلا
باستثناء طبعا المزيد من التنسيق بين
الخطوات التي ربما سوف تتخذ المجموعه
الجديده التي ستكون بديله بديلا لمجموعه
فاقدر وبين الكريم الذي يجب ان يحدد منذ
البدايه في نشاط هذه الشركه الجديده تلك
الخطوط الحمر التي لا يجوز تخطيها باي حال
من الاحوال لكي لا تتكرر قصه بريجوجل
وتمرده الذي حدث منذ شهرين هناك من اعتبر
السيد هناك من اعتبر ان اصلا الكرملين بدا
يمهد لهذه المرحله الجديده بمعنى نائب
وزير الدفاع الروسي عندما ذهب الى ليبيا
والتقى بحفتر فهم وكان ان هناك قناه اخرى
غير قناه فاجنر وغير قناه بريكويشن هل
الولايات المتحده ايضا كانت منزعجه من
موضوع فاجنر والنفط الليبي ما توقعات
بالنسبه للمرحله المقبله على الاقل على
مستوى نفط ليبيا او الثروات الافريقيه
الاخرى
حسنا مجموعه
كانت اداه مهمه لروسيا لاستخراج
ثروات الطبيعيه والاتيان بها الى روسيا
لتغذيه الحرب في اوكرانيا النقطه التي
اثرتموها قبل قليل ايضا الصحيحه الان
فاقدر طبعا
شعبويه اذا مصحه تعبير بخلاف ما كان عليه
الحال في عام 2018 في عام 2018 كان هنالك
ذراع مسلح روسي وكانت فاجنر كانت تعمل
لروسيا ولكن كانت هناك ضبابيه تلفها
مجموعه فاقنر
مختلفه الان وهي تتحدث عن على العلنه
والجميع يعرف انها ربيب روسيا او وكيلته
لروسيا والجميع
حزب الله انه وكيله او ربيبه ايران وهذا
طبعا مقارنه ولكنها ليست مقارنه جيده ولكن
كان هناك الكثير مما فقدته مجموعه الفاجره
في علاقتها مع وبالتالي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تنظر الى فاقنار وكانها امتداد
رسمي اكثر مما كان عليه الحال في السابق
للكريم طبعا ولكن هل هل من السهل على
موسكو دكتور
زياد ماجد طمانه القاده الافارقه في
مجموعه من الدول بان المرحله المقبله لا
خوف عليكم منها ستظل الامور بنفس الوتيره
ومصالحكم مضمونه هل هذه ستكون مهمه شاقه
الى حد ما
هي مهمه رئيسيه بالنسبه لموسكو التي تريد
ان تظهر استمراريه لسياستها ولقدرتها على
استقطاب وجذب دول جديده الى حلفها لا سيما
في افريقيا حيث ارض نزاع اساسيه مع الدول
الغربيه لاسباب اقتصاديه سياسيه وطبعا
تستفيد موسكو من الماضي الكولونيالي
الاوروبي تحديدا لتؤلب رايا عاما لا
يتعاطف مع دول الغرب ولتكسب المزيد من
التاييد لها لكن في نفس الوقت حسابات
العديد من زعماء الدول الافريقيه مرتبطه
ايضا بالاقتصاد وليست فقط بما يمكن لموسكو
ان تمده من دعم عبر ميليشيات او مرتزقه او
عبر الاطر الرسميه وموسكو لا تملك مقومات
دعم اقتصادي لحلفائها تعول احيانا على
الصين لهكذا دعم لكن تكيين ليست تحت امره
موسكو بل هي عملاق اقتصادي لديه حساباته
لذلك الدول الاف في العديد من حالاتها
تفضل ان تبقي شعره معاويه او ان تبقي جسرا
ما مع الدول الغربيه لكي تحصل وتحديدا مع
واشنطن مساعدات اقتصاديه احيانا او اذا
ساءت الامور مع موسكو ان يكون لديها
امكانيه العوده الى علاقات مع دول الغربيه
موسكو عليها ان تدير بدقه تحالفاتها وتشعب
هذه التحالفات بين المصالح الامنيه ودعم
انقلابيين او حكومات او قوى متصارعه في
عدد من الدول الاستراتيجيه لموسكو ولكن في
نفس الوقت هناك حدود للعلاقه ولتحالف بسبب
الاقتصاد وبسبب العلاقات القديمه مع
العديد من الدول الغربيه وبالتالي هذه
التوازنات هي سمه ايضا من سمات المرحله
المقبله مع اشكال متغيره او من دونر من
خلال
المباشره بين موسكو ودول الافريقيه
المعنيه خاصه ان العديد منها ذكرتم ليبيا
ولكن جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى فيها الكثير
من الثروات التي تحاول موسكو
الاستيلاء عليها او على الاقل عبر عقود
الحصول عليها وطبعا ليبيا بسبب موقعها على
المتوسط
والجهه شرق المتوسط هي ساحه مهمه جدا لدول
غربيه منافسه اوروبيه ايطاليا وفرنسا بشكل
خاص ولكن ايضا الولايات المتحده بطبيعه
الحال والصين ودول اقليميه مثل تركيا
جميعها عيونها الان على ما سيجري وعلى
التبدلات التي يمكن ان تنشا بعد مقتل
بريكوجين والخضه التي ستعاني منها فاجنور
ويعني تداعيات ذلك على الحضور الروسي في
المنطقه اداره هذه المرحله بدقه كما ذكرت
هل تقتضي سيد سيد ان يسارع بوتين
بتعيين خليفه البروجين لان اي اي فتره
فراغ في الوسط ستكون
ثقيله من حيث التكلفه
لا هذه الفتره فتره الفراغ كما تفضلت يمكن
ملئها بسهوله من خلال مثلا تزويد الدول
الافريقيه مع تلك التي تحتاج الى ذلك
بالحبوب كما وعد بذلك الرئيس الروسي في
اثناء القمه الروسيه الافريقيه لمؤخره
التي عقدت في اواخر شهر يوليو الماضي وهو
وعد بتقديم يعني بتزويدها بالحبوب اما
مجانا او على اساس تجاري لكن وفقا للوضع
الاقتصادي لهذا البلد الافريقي اوزاك لذلك
ومن جهه اخرى يعني الرئيس الروسي لا يحب
السرعه في قراراته لا يحب قرارات سريعه
بتاثير ربما بعض التطورات
المؤقته التي ربما يمكن ان تؤثر على مزاجه
او على الاجواء السياسيه والى اخره وانما
لاعتقد بانه هو سوف يسرع في اتخاذ هذا
القرار
وليشك ان هذا الموضوع الدراسه وسوف ياتي
الى اختيار شخص ربما يستجيب لتلك المعايير
التي تعتبر الرئيسيه من وجهه نظ لكن هذا
لن يحدث قريبا جدا ربما بعد مرور فتره
معينه من الان ولكن في الاثناء هل يمكن ان
يرسل بعض المبعوثين الى دول افريقيه مثلما
تم ارسال نائب وزير الدفاع الى ليبيا
والتقى بحفتر لان الامر ربما يقتضين نوع
من الطمانه
لحلفاء روسيا في تلك المنطقه في افريقيا
نعم هذا الامر لا يجوز ان نسقطه من الحساب
ويبدو ان هناك اتفاقات اوليه او تمهيديه
تم عقدها والتوصل اليها بهذا الشان في
اثناء القمه نظرا لكثافه الاتصالات
الشخصيه بين الرئيس الروسي والنزرائه
الافارقه ليس طبعا من خلال الجلسات العامه
وانما في اتصالات منفرده عقدها الرئيس
الروسي مع العديد من القضاء على فريق
الذين حضروا هذه القمه وربما سنرى قريبا
زيارات مماثله لتلك التي تفضلت وزير
الدفاع الى ليبيا في يناير الماضي السيد
واشنطن صنفت باغنر على انها منظمه اجراميه
عابره للحدود هل تتوقع ان واشنطن ربما ترى
في هذه الفتره خاصه اذا تاخر نوعا ما
تعويض بريكوجن على ان فتره قد تكون مناسبه
لا اقول توجيه ضربه لبغنر ولكن على الاقل
محاوله الحد من تاثيرها في مناطق هامه في
الساحل في افريقيا مثلا على وجه الخصوص
لان هي المرحله هي المنطقه المتفجره حاليا
للغايه اعتقد ان هنالك امران
يجريان في واشنطن
نقاشات
مرتبطه
بوسمي فاجنر
منظمه ارهابيه لا اعتقد هنالك توافق في
الاراء في امريكا بشان ذلك واذا ما فعل
ذلك فهذا لن يغير شيئا
ملموسا في العلاقه بين الامريكيه وروسيا
الوقت المتحده
الامريكيه في حقيقه الامر سيما ووزاره
الدفاع لا تحبذ العمل في دول الساحل او في
افريقيا عموما
سيما القرن الافريقي لان هذا يعود الى
بلاد التسعينات وما حصل من احداث داميه
ولكن هنالك عمليات خاصه في دول الس تحاول
ان تدرب
وتسلح بعض البلدان
للحاق هزيمتين بحركه الشباب او بقوه حرام
او غيرها ولكن على العموم لا يريد احد في
امريكا ان يعلق في نزاع في افريقيا بسبب
مجموعه
وهذا ما يخفف من اي تصريحات تتاتى من
واشنطن هل يمكن دكتور ماجد
ان تكون المرحله المقبله مرحله خروج فضائح
انساحه التعبير لان في الفتره الاخيره
وقعت تلميحات لان بريجوجل يعيشوا حياه
مرفهه وهناك في قصر في سنه وغيره ربما
المرحله المقبله ستعمل فيها الاله
الاعلاميه الروسيه على اظهار فضائح وفساد
وتجاوزات هل يمكن ان نشهد الوجه الاخر من
العمله فضائح وفساد لقاده افارقه ومسؤولين
فارقه
مرتبطينر وبريجوجين تحديدا
نعم من الممكن جدا ان
تشهد وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وبعض حلقات
النقاش على تيليجرام وغيرها
تسريب معلومات ووثائق حول عقود واتفاقات
وحول الثروات التي استفادت منها فاجنر
هناك تقارير كما ذكرت مثلا مجله فوردس ان
يملك حوالي ثلاثه مليارات دولارات هناك في
المقابل كلام من قبل فاغنر ومن قبل نفسه
في السابق عن الاثراء غير المشروع لضباط
في الجيش الروسي وفي الاداره الروسيه
واستخدم ذلك بطريقه شعبويه ليؤلب الراي
العام على القاده الروس وعلى اخفاقاتهم في
حرب اوكرانيا بلا شك ان تصفيه الحسابات في
دوله يعني لا يوجد فيها معايير من
الشفافيه ودوله قانون بالمعنى الحقيقي
للكلمه كل ذلك ممكن وهذا ينطبق ايضا في
المقابل على شركاء هذه الدوله في افريقيا
والكثير من الانظمه الافريقيه الذين
تتعاون معهم موسكو اتوا بانقلابات وعبر
صراعات داخليه وهذا بلا شك ممكن فقط اذا
سمحت لي ملاحظتين على ما تفضل به الزميلين
في موسكو واشنطن لا اعتقد ان مساله الحبوب
هي بهذه السهوله الان بين موسكو والدول
الافريقيه لاسباب ترتبط بوضع البحر الاسود
ترتبط بعدم الاتفاق بين روسيا واوكرانيا
وتركيا على اعاده تصدير القمح من دون
التفاوض من جديد على بعض الامور وبالتالي
هناك وعود نعم هذا بلا شك صحيح لكن
الايفاء بها ليس بهذه السهوله من دون
اتفاقات اقليميه تسمح بتصدير الحبوب من
جديد
والنقطه الثانيه ان الانكفاء الامريكي عن
الارض الافريقيه عسكريا بسبب تجربه
الصومال وتجارب اخرى سيئه لوشنطن يجر يجري
التعويض عنه عبر الاجهزه المخابراتيه وعبر
الحضور في البحر لان باب المندب او
المنطقه الفاصله بين افريقيا
وبين المحيط الهندي والبحر الاحمر هي من
اكثر المناطق الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
اليوم وكل الاطلاله على البحر الاحمر هي
محل نزاعات تفسر بعض الشيء ما يجري في
اثيوبيا والسودان واريتريا ومجرى نهر
النيل وكم الثروات الموجوده هناك وطبعا
الموقع الاستراتيجي في مواجهه الخليج
وثرواته النفطيه والغازيه فكل هذه الامور
لا يمكن اسقاطها من المتابعه ومن الرصد
ومن المواقف الامريكيه تجاهها وليس فقط
طبعا الروسيه او الاوروبيه وطبعا الصينيه
التي لا ينبغي اسقاطها وهي موجوده بقوه في
هذه المنطقه سؤال في النهايه نفس السؤال
لضيوفنا باختصار شديد لو سمحتم سابدا
بالسيد ثم اعود للدكتور ماجد وانهي بضيفنا
من موسكو ما ابرز تحدي الان مطروح على
موسكو لمرحله ما بعد بريكوجين نبدا بالسيد
تحدي الاكبر هو كالتالي اذا ما رزوا
استخدام نموذج المرتزقه كيف يمكن ضبطه
وكيف يمكن درء تمرد قادم هذا طبعا لن يحصل
غدا ولكن مشكله تجنيد المرتزقه يمكن ان
تفضي الى مشاكل المرتزقه يمكن ان يطعنوا
في الظهر ويمكن ان يكون خونه واذا ما تم
الاعتماد على مجموعه فاغنر
وشبيهاتها فان فان المساله تكون كالتالي
كيف يمكن تعزيز الامن والسلامه وفي تاريخ
الحرب عن طريق شركات امنيه خاصه هي حرب
بطبيعه الحال دفلته من عقالها دائما هذا
هو التحدي الاساسي دكتور ماجد
رغم ان ظل يعني وفيا لبوتين وجنبه كل
الانتقادات التي كان يواجهها للنخبتين
العسكريه والسياسيه في موسكو الا ان قتله
الان وبعض التغييرات التي جرت في الوقت
نفسه في هيئه الاركان الروسيه وفي قياده
العمليات في اوكرانيا رغم انها تعيد
الاعتبار لسيد الكرملين كقائد وحيد
واوحد لروسيا الا انها تخلق حاله من الخوف
والرعب كان يمكن ان تكون لصالحه لو ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا تسير بشكل جيد لكن في
ظل استمرار الحرب والمصاعب الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه هناك بلا شك تعب في الوسط
السياسي الروسي
اخيرا سيد سيد باختصار شديد لو سمحت
باختصار شديد اعتقد بان على القياده
الروسيه الان ان توجه تحديات طبعا بعد ما
حدث ولا شك ان الكريم الان ربما سيكون
مشغول بايجاد صيغ مقبوله
لكي تكون بديلا لشركه وربما ذلك من خلال
اجتنان جديدات العسكريه بشكل عام في روسيا
على اساس قانوني وليس من قبيل صدفه ان هذا
الموضوع ينظر اليه الان شكرا لضيوفنا
جميعا سيد سيدي الدكتور زياد ماجد والسيد
شون بهذا نصل الى نهايه البرنامج
الان
الى الح